ich mache so lange wie es geht in
anführungszeichen bis ich wirklich sehr
okay jetzt pelz ich meine haut im leben
oder solarium ist für mich geht gar
nicht ein leben ohne solarium ist für
mich geht gar nicht naja herzlich konnte
diese leute ich hab mir heute für uns
ein ganz besonderes video rausgesucht
und zwar geht es bei diesem video das
wir uns heute anschauen werden um ein
video das nach außen den anschein
erweckt es ist eine häufige folge das
einzige problem ist nur es ist nicht von
hilf mir die geschichte ist echt konkret
geht es um die doku-soap folge also ist
eine echte person hilfe wir sind süchtig
nach solarium will dann erst mal
reinschauen werden mal gucken was es
damit auf sich hat und stichwort solange
man hautfarbe ich teste heute nur neue
kamera sollte ich in diesem video also
lila aussehen liegt es daran in sceaux
bräunung beschleuniger gehören zur
vorbereitung michaela und der wir tun
alles um noch dunkler zu werden bloß nie
wieder blass ok also so beiden
kandidaten heißen michaela und david und
deren einziges ziel im leben ist
scheinbar glücklich dunkel zu werden auf
diesem bild erkennen können wurden sie
zumindest schon mal nicht dunkel
geworden sind wahrscheinlich europäer
also leute die also im land kommen was
bei uns wahrscheinlich in der nähe ist
aber scheinbar hat sich eines tages der
blitz getroffen und jetzt haben sie sich
entschieden dass jetzt dunkel sein
müssen also sie kommentieren dieses bild
hier auf der linken seite mit den worten
alter schwede
damals sahen wir richtig schlimm aus ich
bin froh dass wir nicht mehr so aussehen
wir werfen einen blick drauf wir auf der
linken seite ganz normale station
irgendwie im bus so ok ob die
sonnenbrille ist bisschen funky okay da
kann ich verstehen dass man das so wie
man ein bisschen so wegschieben will von
sich aber ich schaue ich die rechte
seite was ist da jetzt besser geworden
also ich will wirklich nicht hätten
leute aber der hautfarbe hat sich
gefühlt einfach weiter in richtung
rindswurst entwickelt ich mache so lange
wie es geht und anführungszeichen dass
ich wirklich sehr okay jetzt plötzlich
meine haut im leben oder solarium ist
für mich geht gar nicht ein leben ohne
solarium ist für mich geht gar nicht
sie geht sogar noch einen schritt weiter
und zeigt sie macht so lange weiter bis
ihre haut fällt das ist lange dauert es
nicht mehr bis zu viermal pro woche
lässt sich das pärchen von der
künstlichen sonne braten beide anfang 20
beide noch in der ausbildung aber auch
süchtig nach
sie müssen sagen dass dann bis dato auch
noch nicht geläufig dass man süchtig
nach sonnenbank sein kann
das bedeutet letzten endes dass man auch
irgendwo sich nach sonnenstrahlung ist
also auch nach dem bau strahlend sonnig
warme gibt es dann auch leute die sich
nach sonne sind so die einfach nicht in
ihre wohnung reingehen weil sie süchtig
danach sind von der sonne draußen
bestattet zu werden
geige gefunden leute hier kommentiert
bruce und flieg das was dann also das
erste mal ein solarium bin ich schon mit
14 und sind damals noch in sonstwo in
berlin ins solarium gegangen und sind
ewig weit gefahren weil ich auch noch
keine 80 ok warte mal ich will jetzt mal
keinen unsinn zu erzählen okay ich
google ist gerade mal welche auswirkung
hat eigentlich solarium auf die
gesundheit sondern willst du gerne erste
benachrichtigung nicht mal erstes
suchergebnis sondern so der erste
vorschlag ohne und ich erzählt von einer
seite namens netdoktor dass das
künstliche uv licht aus dem solarium
gesund sei ist immer noch ein
verbreiteter irrglaube internationale
und nationale expertengruppen empfehlen
solarien besser zu meiden
die rindswurst transformation zwei junge
menschen die gesamte lebenszeit darin
investieren und sehr viel geld darin
investieren endlich eines tages wie eine
handelsübliche rindswurst auszusehen
trotz monatskarten und flatrates stecken
die beiden sonnenanbeter mehrere tausend
euro im jahr
in ihrem dunklen ein tolles hobby und
extrem gefährlich noch dazu also ich
würde auch nicht nur helden leuten also
ich meine wir kennen das gefühl dass wir
im winter so vom spiel stehen oder in
welche bilder von uns aus dem sommer
sehen uns denken
was für ein camembert belichten geworden
so und dann dass man sich dann denke ich
will wieder brauner werden aber nicht so
dass ich mir sorgen um meine haut es ist
aber in dem moment vergessen weil man
einfach sieht das ist im nachhinein
schön aussieht
das stimmt tatsächlich
bei jeder bekanntlich weiß dass eine
krankheit wie hautkrebs die
möglicherweise auch durch das solarium
begünstigt wird prinzipiell nur bei
leuten auftreten kann die älter als 40
sind also solange mein junges einfach
mal gönnen allein in deutschland
erkranken jährlich mehr als 200.000
menschen an hautkrebs tendenz steigend
wie gefährlich solarien dabei wirklich
sind meistens unterschätzt hautärzte
schlagen alarm
also müssen wir das nach außen aussieht
sollte ist es sieht so aus als würde
irgendjemand sagen ist man die wissen ja
das ist richtig krank schädlich ist und
dazu kommt dass die halt wirklich
aussehen wie ein gekochter krebs im
prinzip ist es so ja ja klar ist es
schädlich für mich egal
nächste woche auf hilfe wir sind süchtig
danach unseren kopf gegen die wand zu
hauen rein sonst die haut sehr schädlich
ja jeder einzelne tagungsbesucher
schädigt die haut vor sich vorstellen
ist ungefähr so als würde man sich am
äquator in die mittagssonne legen als
vergleich damit leute ich will mich
nicht über die sache also nicht lustig
mache und ich hab mir auch mal gedacht
dass ich in meinen sowie jacksons auf
videos bisschen mehr auch real top
machen wir doch nicht nur jobs machen
will also es ist schon so was dahinter
steht erkennt ihr glaube ich auch ne das
ist dieser schönheitswahn in unserer
gesellschaft dass leute unbedingt
perfekt aussehen möchten und dafür
wirklich auch einkaufen dem sich selbst
zu schädigen hauptsache man sie gut aus
er wird von anderen wahrgenommen so dass
es das problem dahinter das haben wir
auf keinen fall vergessen aber wie hit
geld 43 ist werden sie wenigstens braun
das ist euro
das ist einfach ein gefühl der
ausgeglichenheit das war einfach
angenehm darunter zu liegen und noch
dazu ist fühlt weiß ich natürlich
also ja es ist genau das was ich gesagt
habe es ist dieser schöne als waren der
unsere generation auch extrem plagt also
gerade im zug von instagram wo jeder
versucht so schön und sexy wie möglich
auszusehen und ich muss sagen deswegen
auch wenn das normalerweise meine art
ist nicht immer sachen wird nächste
woche das ist ein echter fall das kann
sich in dem fall hier nicht so gut leute
die tun ja auch ein bisschen leid new
york michaela und david blenden die
gefahren für haut und leben komplett aus
ihre beste freundin jedoch nicht immer
wieder redet charlie den beiden ins
gewissen
wirklich mal leute applaus für diese
frau so was ist wirklich wichtig im
leben okay noch mal kurz an der stelle
freunde im leben die einem sagen wo an
der stelle übertreibst ist wirklich
gerade richtig krass oder auch bereits
ins gesicht zu sagen sind extrem wichtig
so sehr gut aber eine frage die ich nach
wie vor nicht aus dem kopf bekommen ist
wann sagen die beiden für sich selbst
mal so jetzt ist schluss wenn die
aussehen wie ein schoko weihnachtsmann
ohne alufolie oder wie also ist aber
machen uns nichts vor leute wir wissen
alle dass probleme und gerade
gesundheitliche probleme von diesem
ausmaß nicht davon weg gehen dass man
einfach nicht zum arzt geht ohne
wirtsleute live und weiß immer den
problemen und unangenehmen wahrheiten
stellen es ist besser zu wissen okay ich
bin am arsch als nicht zu wissen bin ich
vielleicht am arsch und dann darüber
gedanken zu machen sobald man das
problem kennt kann man es angehen eine
woche später david und michaela können
sich doch noch zu einem termin beim
hautarzt überwinden auch wenn der weg
alles andere als einfach für die beiden
ist also ich muss wirklich sagen so
absurd es auch ist dass man sich
vorstellt dass deutete sich das solarium
ist ich kann irgendwie nicht mehr helfen
ich sehe die ganze zeit parallelen zum
rauchen so also wenn ihr mehr in der
liga folgt dann wisst ihr dass ich auch
mal genau damit
mai aufgehört habe und es ist irgendwie
voll ähnlich oder es ist nicht exakt das
gleiche
ich bin gelaufen ist auch ungesund und
schlecht aber es ist nicht ganz so crazy
wie süchtig nach solarium zu sein aber
es ist beides ok ich hab' irgendwas was
mir irgendwie ein bisschen ein kick gibt
spaß gibt aber ich weiß es schädigt mein
körper einfach krass aber ich muss
trotzdem gut beim ein wird man halt
nicht orange aber also der erste
eindruck war
man sieht sofort diese haut hat viel zu
viel uv strahlen gesehen die haut wird
deutlich vor gealtert ich würde schätzen
circa zehn jahre gerne noch größere
schäden bei de wit weiter entfernt ist
das aber von wake up käufer irgendwo da
draußen hat von euch der in bis hin zu
oft ins solarium geht also wie gesagt
das ist nachvollziehbar so dass man im
schön aussehen will auch im winter
geräumt sein wird ich mein guck mich
also ich bin lila gerade eigentlich herr
bock wieder zu sein
nein ich würde auch gerne lieber so
leicht angebrannt also ist für mich auf
jeden fall sehr schockierend stolzen das
schon haut einer älteren dame ist weil
es natürlich irgendwann wirklich sehr
[Gelächter]
waren leute oder jetzt nehmen wir das
nicht übel aber ich brauche über
parallel beim schauen von diesem video
auch bei den ernsten passage solistin
die kommentare löst und ich das aber zu
trocken gewesen also ich muss es
wirklich so deutlich sagen tut mir
wirklich leid ja kommentare wie die sind
so orange weil ich diese stelle ich die
mittel ton raus in bezug auf solare
werde ich mich auf jeden fall ein
bisschen abstand halten jetzt nicht mehr
so oft in die welt zu gehen ist
vielleicht zu reduzieren weil ganz
aufhören das wahrscheinlich erstmal
unmöglich ohne wird heute ich finde
dieses video das nochmal so krass
gezeigt auch wenn ich verstehen kann
dass leute irgendwie das bedürfnis haben
wir mehr dazuzugehören oder schöner zu
sein so um diese ziele zu erreichen
seinem eigenen körper zu schaden zum
beispiel indem man raucht oder krankhaft
oft ins solarium geht der kleine besser
schreibt mich jetzt mal an die
kommentare was sie von diesem video in
diesem thema im allgemeinen haltet und
danach check
für euch vorschlages video ausführen
könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren leute
das ist mein letztes video aus dem jahr
2009 10 aus diesem jahrzehnt alter ich
danke euch fürs zuschauen die ganze zeit
und heute auch wieder und ich küsse
augen ihr seid die besten
macht's gut